can I hit it tuna Sally please pick tuna
they can read the rock I reject nation
I'm Greg album this is a man no Sally
Lamanna coats here guys follow her on
everything right away got your plug out
of the way mom and choco it's the
correct way to pronounce it after all
these years I finally learned so Sally
there isn't anything from what culture
this could make for an interesting
reaction
well coach girl they do like this video
is they're British they're funny I know
why they're so charming we're gonna
watch this video for them ten more
movies so awful they were pulled from
cinemas ten more movies so there must
have been 10 movies list
yeah that we didn't see but we're gonna
go to ten more let's get to it
enough talking video starts at one
minute twenty whatever people say in the
comments you know they hate
introductions it's no secret
big fan like transformers terrible
horrors like rings and completely
misguided dramas like the book of Henry
or all the dime a dozen
quite a lot these days for a film to
really stand out in it to see a
painfully dreadful release but I was is
to see how long it took before the
distributor's pulled from theaters
it doesn't matter of something cost 1
million dollars or 100 million sometimes
it's better to just pretend it didn't
happen at all and we've already covered
even the worst offense before but those
were only the beginning
I'm Josh from what culture calm and
these are 10 more movies so long we have
cinemas but before we begin don't forget
to subscribe to spin notified ding ding
don't number 10 show dogs sure dogs on
this list to not only get pulled from
cinemas once but twice within the space
of its shot theatrical run after only a
week in screams and suffering a critical
picking distributors decided to take the
film out of circulation in response to
incessant complaints about a scene that
allegedly quote-unquote normalized child
grooming where what was obviously no
filmmaker in the world wants their kids
movie to be associated with those kinds
of messages and the theatrical cut was
returned to the editing room to
eliminate the controversial scenes
eventually put back into circulation the
backlash had seemingly all the shallowed
show dogs his fundamental flaw it wasn't
a good movie
regardless ultimately the flake only
lasted a couple more weeks and theaters
given the boot after a cumulative four
and a half week run caning it entirely
might have been the best move the studio
medval because if nobody can remember
the movie then they probably won't
remember the controversy either no but
now their kid makes you at the Wellness
I saw this really on this list the cure
for wellness had all the signs of a
major flop long before it released no it
had a pretty strong cast it was coming
from acclaimed director Dog Pinsky a
two-and-a-half-hour r-rated gothic
horror that's more focused a melodrama
than scares was always going to be a
difficult sell can it didn't help that
the movie itself while ambitious failed
to offer the story or the horror
necessary to really appeal to a specific
audience as a result of movie lasted
only 35 days in theaters should be noted
that it only received a wide release for
its first couple weekends with the movie
going from being available in nearly
3,000 theaters to a mere 80 in the span
of one week number eight heavens get
always cinematic failure of all-time
haven't scared pretty much ended
Hollywood's obsession with ballooning
budgets and giving directors as much
creative control in all lanes of a
dissolution of production company United
Artists and ended director Michael
Caminos career ensuring that he would
never be able to live up to the hot
streak he was on before boarding the
passion project where will the budget
and the final cut come in at a whopping
219 minutes Wow the end result itself
crumbled under its own ambition not even
getting the consolation prize of being a
hit with critics consequently it only
took a single week lighting up cinemas
before United Artists pulled the film
entirely week number 7
Diana wild period pieces especially
period pieces about Elam Emily usually
do fairly well in both Britain and
overseas 2013 diana was doomed from the
start
although critics admittedly noted just
how hard Naomi Watts was trying to make
the film work as the titular princess
the release quickly became one of the
most arriving of the year with just
about every outlet ready to pounce on
not only how terribly handled the
material itself was but how new in the
film was regardless of how it approached
its main subject consequently the movie
never made it past being shown in more
than 100 theaters in the US with the
distribution company keeping it in
circulation they wanted this to be an
Oscar so you could tell us resulting in
it playing in just 26 cinema
during its third in final week before
being pulled all together after that
number six cabin fever 2016 that's right
every made this we make of cabin fever
isn't a terrible idea she where the
original Blake had its charm but it
could be argued that a great concept was
squandered by Eli Roth well being AI
Roth and letting some of his worst
tenancy silicon most of the good
concepts the horror was admittedly built
around that would have taken at least a
little bit of creativity in filmmaking
talent though two things which i have
seen midnight clearly didn't consider
when they went into production on their
remake though a limited theatrical run
wash plant and did technically Happy's
more reception and world wanted or
needed in almost shot-for-shot remake
meant that it only showed up in 22
British cinemas for two weekends
bringing in $9,000 and then going
straight to be able T nullified Gigli
Julius Korea
Geely ensued that everyone involved
would remain a laughingstock in the
industry for years following its release
it was so bad that it resulted in
director Martin breasts hanging up his
hat completely retiring from behind the
camera work due to the overwhelming
hatred the film garnered is that
immediate response which essentially
turned the picture into a mean before
memes
even existed alongside a huge eighty-one
percent decline from first week box
office numbers to the second even the
studio slashed its availability from all
the 2000 theaters to only 73 in its
third week of release 2,073
weekend new McFaul German the holidays
bro chief success with live-action
adaptations of their biggest properties
such as GI John transformers Universal
Pictures wanted in on the action
signing a six film contract with the
studio in 2006 battleship and we gia all
eyes were on the studio to see which
other famous property would be made next
out of everything though nobody expected
Jaron the Holograms to be next in line
for a big-screen adaptation and to be
honest in better hands the properties
blend of music and fantasy could have
resulted in a charming surprise but from
the get-go ins clear the studio didn't
care much better than the project
allotting a tiny five million dollar
budget which it didn't end up recouping
for director john energy to work with
after a dreadful alternate Universal
couldn't wait to get the movie off their
hands and pulled it completely after two
weeks of release number three
revolution a movie that stars Al Pacino
as a man forced to take part in the
revolutionary war after his son is
kidnapped by British forces it is a
premise which on pepper seemingly
couldn't fail objects it wouldn't be on
this list if that was true and the movie
ended up taking primarily because
production was rushed to secure it
December release said in order for it to
be eligible for the next award season
boy where they where they hope that
front the end result itself was so bad
in fact that it forced Al Pacino to go
on an extended break from acting all
together taking a four-year hiatus an
only returning in 1989 see of lo it
initially only opened in one studio
assess the damage of the scathing
reviews then releasing the film and even
more cinemas the following week but
decided it can distribution entirely
after 16 days on the market number two
United passions a film about fever 490
percent by cleaver themselves was never
going to paint the cooperation in a
negative light allegedly that was the
entire point of United passions
existence though with the
movie being commissioned to transform
the image of the organization in the
public eye
after years of claims of corruption and
shady business practices can to define
the footballing board unsurprisingly
then it was immediately torn apart by
critics not only for its self
aggrandizing skewed presentation of the
subject matter but because even without
that bogging it down it was just a pool
amid film while a bad reception alone
isn't enough to get a movie is the USA
released coincident with the 2015 FIFA
corruption investigation ensuring a
meager 3-day run in theatres number one
him oh Emily pimp is one of the worst
movies ever made the passion project
written directed and produced by Robert
Cabana and also starring Danny Dyer
pretty much put every foot wrong line
with a narrative as ugly as the film's
visuals this script is a mess the acting
is wooded in the film is shot in such a
half as it we handled where that it
generally becomes disorientating
predictably it was devoured by critics
upon release and the movie was pulled
after one day a good movie screening
went wrong in a whopping total box
office draws Fisher Washington central
room into five pounds yes you heard that
right
not two hundred thousand two hundred in
five pounds do the mammals in assume
that the average ticket cost around nine
pounds and that means around twenty
people got to see this film in all its
glory that's to lucky soem sells more
people to talk to you about a brand new
project that we're gonna have starting
up pretty soon is that brand new channel
called that film Theory place of which
is gonna be a bit more relaxed this is
the cinematic experiences
[Laughter]
passion about it it comes to boil that's
cool that film theory though cinemasins
dude this is a really sad list for sure
really sad this movie show dogs they
said something about child grooming
being like definitely said child they
didn't show anything about the
controversial scene that was like taking
out I was like did that come up this
year I don't remember seeing it
advertised but it looks familiar to me
it looks very familiar I know yeah came
out this year May 2018 and it also looks
like the kind of movie that would do
okay with families I don't know about a
may release that's pretty awful though
man it may have been an issue just like
pixels were like pixels I loved that
movie but it was marketed to be a kids
movie kind of like this and then you go
see it and it has like I'm saying their
humor and it was like to me it looks
like that might have been the issue or
is marketed as a kids movie and then
they just had controversial jokes in it
that just didn't mesh well with families
one question you should ask yourself in
making a movie is what's my target
audience it's crazy to me to hear about
how a lot of these movies initially
start off with like we're playing in
thousands of theaters and then they go
down to playing them less than a hundred
by the next week what do you think I
mean if we connect here for a while this
is not a terrible film I actually
enjoyed that movie I could see why it
was hard for the movie to latch on to
the mainstream audience it's also a very
long movie and it's not exactly like
filled with horror throughout its the
guy who did Pirates of the Caribbean the
first three and it rang healed
yeah I wasn't entirely surprised it
didn't perform all that great but I
thought it was creepy and fun and stuff
man I feel kind of bad for that I feel
bad for Dane DeHaan he's so good cuz
he's a really talented actor but he
keeps starring in things that just are
not yeah not received well it's like
Glary an amazing spider-man 2 it's like
the underperform with critics and box
office every time but he's a very
that actors I thought he was a better
Green Goblin than it was pretty cool I
was damn sure they were going to go with
Norman Osborn know looking up Heaven's
Gate he won the Razzie for worst
director this is crazy there's a big
cast in here man he got Christopher
Walken here John Hurt Sam Waterston and
this guy he directed the deer hunter
which is a cinematic classic it always
pains me when I hear about a director
who was this high up and then they just
that's already one one they're gonna
keep trying to go bigger and bigger and
it seems like what he said is that they
just ran out of time so they had to rush
it and sometimes when they get to a
point where they have no restraints that
could either be a great thing or a
terrible thing this is 219 minute movie
I will never sit down and watch it even
looking at this footage of Mike's looks
so nothing appealing about this and then
a couple of cool shots here there's in
good production this time this Diana
movie which I've never heard of just
looking at this they wanted this to be
an award incineration biopic Helen
Mirren Naomi Watts this like true story
of a princess Diana which had a terrible
tragedy happen they wanted like Oscar
material in here it's pretty crazy when
you get this caliber of talent and it
gets this limited of release in such a
short amount of time and make no one
ends up going to watch it the sad part
about this to me especially is just
looking at the footage I didn't hear an
audio I'm like Naomi Watts looks like
she really committed to this and
probably tried you said the biggest
crush on her in the first ring we should
watch it yeah to support that childhood
crush that I used to have cabin fever
2016 the first cabin fever came out in
2003 and then they did a shot-for-shot
remake ten years later less than that I
think this is mm a little more than that
it's 2016
why would you remake a movie so fast
you should ask Sony that with spider-man
that's different
at least they were trying to do they
were trying to do it a little different
here they didn't like the exact same way
carry oh my god
when they remade carry I was like it's
the same like they just with less heart
yeah exactly I mean I could get it
though if it's been like so many decades
the gap between carry original and then
carry remake is so vast that it can make
sense to me why you do it the 13 years
that's like the most pointless idea I've
ever heard cabin fever videocam fever
like for if you want to do something I
don't have recounted fevers are bid this
came out two years after the third one
[Laughter]
and then Gigli oh god you remember that
my friend put the movie on one time we
were just like hanging out in the
apartment I was dying I got to tell you
something so I watched it and I cannot
register why I was so terrible I got
that it's not a good movie but I don't
get why it was like the most hated movie
ever no I think like fans because the
acting level when you put them together
it's just it's weird it's like a weird
pairing I don't know they were engaged
when this movie was coming out and
what's funny is they had no chemistry in
this movie like people were I think
expecting like a mr. mrs. Smith sort of
like great chemistry
it's movie has Walken and Pacino in it
but you know I gotta say that one of my
favorite things about Gigli is how much
bed Affleck there's a kind of a funny
trajectory in benefice career with Gigli
and what he did with his personal life
following this film because he embraced
how everyone thought it was horrible I
remember he went on The Tonight Show and
he's like you know I just want to read
you guys some of the good reviews and
then he just started reading the worse
things
wasn't about the movie but in like the
cleverest ways so he was embracing he
went on The Tonight Show and did that
and then he went on SNL and he did a
whole sketch or he's like filming the
movie he's like so penny like it was
gonna be a huge hit like he embraced it
and I think exactly I think in a weird
way it led to people liking him because
of how he handled his movie being so Pam
where the director he quit directing
like anything whereas Ben Affleck
somehow managed to recover from this
yeah gem in the hologram was upset about
because did you want to see this I just
kind of was upset cuz I was like finally
they're doing kind of an all-girl cast
of something from the past I remember
why it got so much heat because it
centered around her getting popular off
of YouTube or something so it's like
clearly the writers didn't understand
social media and so it was just a cheesy
like oh I posted a cover and it went
viral now we're in this big band it's
like it just did you actually see it I
didn't see it no I was reading reviews
when I came out of it just I saw clips
from it the cool thing is that director
he's gone on to do crazy rich Asians
which is doing phenomenal right now
sometimes I'm actually a list video like
this it's either something super sad or
there's kind of a cool story of comeback
GI Joe to Justin Bieber's believe in one
year that seeks talent I think this guy
worked on a lot of music video types of
step up he's done three of the step up
movies yeah this united passions movie
just sound like I I didn't realize
people gonna have that much power to
produce one movie to try to make
yourselves look good it was produced by
the people behind FIFA to try to make
FIFA look good after all the controversy
has had I didn't realize there are
companies that would do that and then
when I heard that even though everyone's
saying this is a terrible film I
remember how pan this movie was
one of Nikes gonna do an egg yeah this
is gonna be a Papa John's movie next or
a chick-fil-a or something like that
in-n-out burgers in trouble now which
all company all companies that get like
a bad rap it's just like do a movie
about yourself now to make it look good
like the founder that pound out really
well hence the main one I saw the most
interesting I can get on board with a
terrible film as long as it's
entertainment yeah if it's boring that's
one thing that this looks like this
could be an entertaining ly bad time I
can be on board for that
everyone watch your first list anyway
thanks black culture for your time I
appreciate you very much
Sally appreciates you and I appreciate
Sally guys you can subscribe to what
culture subscribe to the real rejects
click our notification though more
importantly follow Sally
I almost said salamander Sally you can
call me [ __ ] dead in the water
that fish is dead whole new tuna
swimming around here her name's Sally
Lomonaco can I hit it tuna Sally please
[Music]
give me money on patreon and follow
Sally hunt YouTube and Instagram and all
that and then go to their patreon and
support the real rejects because you
just told me some new stuff that they're
working on and you're gonna want to keep
updated so I was very good appreciate
the confidence
[Laughter]